yesterday joe biden stood before the
world and proclaimed that the taliban's
takeover of afghanistan came as a total
surprise
the assumption was that more than 300
000 afghan national security forces that
we had trained over the past two decades
and equipped
would be a strong adversary
in their civil wars with the taliban
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate yeah well
that was an obvious lie he also said the
same thing pretty much to stephanopoulos
on abc so according to reuters now and
here you don't want to miss this and
it's it's true it's not the babylon bee
biden knew that the collapse was
inevitable he just didn't want anyone
else to know about it in late july
during a phone call with president
ashraf ghani biden told him
to pretend like the taliban wasn't ready
to retake the country saying quote
i need not tell you the perception
around the world and in parts of
afghanistan i believe is that things
aren't going well in terms of the fight
against the taliban and there's a need
whether it's true or not
there's a need to project a different
picture
joining me now to react is retired army
infantry captain and u.s senate
republican candidate sean parnell
sean i think that this is this is not
like guesswork or rhetoric or hyperbole
there there was that is a confession a
recognition that the country was in
trouble and asking the president of
afghanistan effectively to lie
about what was going on which means also
you will not be prepared because you
can't prepare because you're telling
people something that's not true
what are your thoughts on this
well it's it's absolutely unbelievable
but nobody should be surprised joe biden
has been a politician in washington for
50 years and lying is what he does he
said he graduated at the top of his law
school that was a lie said he had three
degrees that was a lie said that he
opposed the iraq war that was a lie said
he was the first uh in his family to go
go to college in a thousand generations
that was a lie he said he was a coal
miner from pennsylvania that was a lie
too that's what this man does i mean for
goodness sake he said he was in a knife
fight with a guy named corn pop so
you know
when we think back on this sean it's
unbelievable but and it tells you one
thing lying about yourself it gives
people a hint about your character and
your nature but now the lies
have gotten 13 of our service members
murdered
now the lies untold numbers of of people
in afghanistan will be slaughtered this
is going to be a bloodbath that is i
think what the american people for some
reason have not made the connection yet
about who this man is
that's right and he did this exact same
thing in ukraine
fire the prosecutor who's investigating
my family's corrupt business dealings in
your country or you don't get the
billion dollars right lie about the
conditions on the battlefield and and
otherwise you won't get the military
assistance they don't call him quid pro
joe for nothing and the most horrible
thing about all of this tammy is that he
the fact that he had to lie means that
he knew six weeks ago
that things were going to go bad that's
correct he didn't he didn't adjust his
strategy he didn't warn americans in
that country to leave he didn't tell her
he might be stranded in the embassy we
got rid of that we got rid of we
that all the terrorist prisoners being
released
it's almost as though it was by design
and we've got to consider the nature of
what's happened here and i know it's
shocking i think most of americans are
still in shock but as we get these
details that's what tonight's about sean
tonight is about the the overflow the
lava coming out of the volcano
we must be prepared you know we've got
to be able to look at what's coming up
on our hills thank you so much for
joining me great stuff and uh great to
see you again sean hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else